ich weiß ich weiß wie das ist eigentlich
okay wir kochen will ich auch warum
kommt das heißt das ja kommen weil ich
weiß was kommen wenn du liebe gibt es
das ich so liebe zurück dass er sein
mehr der fall war
[Musik]
so leute ich habe hunger ich kann aber
nicht kochen und kiki ist etwas zu und
zeigt euch das mal so richtig leckere
rezepte auf und hat keine zeit für mich
kommt wo es wirklich gegeben
sowie schauen was hier so gibt
ich habe immer noch keine ahnung wie das
funktioniert ich hab das schon mal
gemacht da ich aber nur höchste
reingesteckt und gegessen aber ich
glaube dass jetzt langweilig doch gehört
keinem christian
lipicki ja hilfst du willst es dabei
aber
nicht so
ich hoffe
das wird jetzt ein video okay
hallo ihr lieben
sie die chance haben seine wirksamkeit
trotzdem drauf auf jeden fall aber wenn
ihr blog von uns sehen möchte dann
solltet ihr den zweit kanal abonnieren
denn heute werden rahmen gepimpt rahmen
sind also hatte ich nur du kennst sie
von früher
jugend und in die jungen kind auch mal
von früher auf jeden fall etwas mehr
oder weniger ein fertiggericht einfach
schnell im wasser garen gewürzmischung
und abgeben
auf jeden fall finden werde jetzt hamza
ich zeig dir zwei varianten du machst
mich okay das ist mit kochen
warum also jetzt muss ich mal willkommen
die rahmenrichtlinie schweren auto er
wird okay die erste variante die wird
cremig ist statt wasser nehmen wir nicht
mehr wie wir kochen wenn ich direkt den
will ich auch ja warum kommt das weißt
du ja kommen
was kann passieren verbrennen
so ich mache heute gar nicht gesagt
einfach was zu machen das so einfach ich
weiß ich weiß wieder so wusste da ist
sie ja eigentlich ein ich weiß was ich
noch viele zuschauer ist gerade aber du
machst du da bist du kann besser reden
das ist okay
das wasser rein damit wirklich schon mal
so ein bisschen vorgang können die bäume
kein problem heißt voll von
wahrscheinlich drei viertel
hälfte recht ja
also einige wissen das ja auch na ich
habe früher habe ich im großhandel
gearbeitet und ich habe das was alle
zwei tage gästen ich habe einfach also
diese android packung wirkung an der
stelle einfach reingelegt kleine
investieren weil die haben alles dort
gehabt im großhandel strich habe selber
einfach gemacht und ich habe noch nie
dazu gepackt karibik hat ja herzlich
wurde voll
okay das ist die gewürzmischung lassen
unsere nudeln legt ihr euch mal ich fand
das geht
dich zu und her machen muss der trick
ist dann wird es auch besser so bisher
aufgeht passieren muss ist das muss
nicht an mir liebe ca
kommen wenn du liebe gibt es das ich so
liebe zurück
auf jeden fall uns doch das schmeckt man
am ende auch
okay ich doch das reicht von insgesamt
nur drei minuten wollen ja weil nämlich
ganz komplett weiß haben dann immer
diesem schirm löffel dahinten gibt
einfach die nudeln diesen abschnitt
in der pfanne ist doch schlimm ist
nur die hälfte sonst wird es zu wird
sich große kübel zugegeben ja immerhin
sonst einfach heute wir nehmen das wie
es uns der einzelhandel geschenkt habt
aber ich bin gerade mit leben wie du
störst mich gerade ich bin gerade hier
live auf geht s kitchen
ok danke ich liebe dich auch tschüss ok
hansa erfahrung war das ziemlich möchten
wir geben dazu keine sahne soße ich
musste sogar nur ein no look
looks good luck in europas fußball
so denkt dann du schießt nach links aber
schließlich
hat so ein bisschen ein makler auf 60
ich mir so viel kalorien ach so ja er
ist noch auf kalorien ich glaube es muss
ein bisschen mehr power haben wir
uns natürlich wenn
da jetzt ohne aufzug warten muss ich
drei machen ja damit dass ein bisschen
besser
angehen um aufzuhören
[Musik]
deutsche schneidest du darfst den auch
schneiden und schweißen
doch jetzt ist es schwierig mit feiner
hätte vorher mal mutter zu kind und
jetzt ja sowieso ein kind sprach dass
vor allem wenn der verein sieht besser
aus
[Musik]
soll ich probier mal gesehen schon so
cremig aus ich kann überhaupt nicht dass
hier
ein bisschen mehr würze business wissen
wie sie ein gewisses tag einstimmen ich
finds gut mir gefällt es so
das waren vor allem nun endlich minuten
arbeit waren das hansa 43 ganze ich mal
das rücktrittsrecht
wenn ihr eure männer du wirst kochen
bringen möchte dann rahmen der bescheid
aber ich würde sagen wir machen mal zwei
okay
klar das ist mir zu machen nummer zwei
es ist bereit und behalten auch bereit
ok zweite rezept wird ein bisschen
anstrengender als erstes ein bisschen zu
leicht für dich will ich mal so man
jetzt zweiter ritter das wird richtig
gepimpt wir haben hier heißes wasser ich
weiß es mal kurz kochen und dann gibst
du dir armen direkter rein und dann wird
das ganze einfach noch gewürzt ich lass
das mal dir ja die bastille liegt ihr
alles oder geschlecht mal in der soße
und kommt mit sich machen ja gemeint
dann mach doch einfach so wenig los das
ist bewusst dass noch mal vereinbart
so sind zwei platten
zwei platten weil sein ich zeige meine
kann ich an unternehmen
eines seiner das ist nur doppelt
sieht gut aus wir haben wasser nochmals
deutlich reduziert wollen uns flüssig
haben ja haben wir wie wärs mal so mit
witzen hier klar meine ziele hast du
machst meister so sehr größter
auslandsmarkt
sagen das riecht doch asia markt
gebracht der packung kommen wir jetzt
also die hälfte als die hälfte kannst du
fandest du es ja ein bisschen zu wenig
würzig dann kannst du das schon lese
alles was man ja
jetzt mache ich bis zum 3
[Musik]
[Applaus]
übertroffen so clique tober und jetzt
warten wir sonst gleicht das machen wir
doch später zu noch so weg um spiele für
die deko sesam und frühlingszwiebeln auf
jeden fall muss das jetzt das eines
stocken und dann verrühren wir das
schöne wird auch noch mal richtig schön
cremig und das dauert ich denke also
geschätzt vielleicht fünf minuten ach so
das spiel verloren
ja ich mag das spiel gleich mal ja ich
benutze das ist lecker
[Musik]
mag das ein bisschen fester geworden ich
finde aber auch okay wenn es noch ein
bisschen flüssig ist und jetzt kochte
das richtig schön verrühren so
war das sieht richtig gut aus sowas
treiber jetzt mit 4 1 so gut wie du
wählen falls ich hoffe dass er so gut
[Musik]
so haben sie jetzt frei was man
probieren uns gekocht
[Musik]
berichte ich wirklich gruselig erstmals
schmeckt sehr
dazu noch beim nächsten mal vergibt den
krieg ja das ist super für ein bisschen
käse bist du mehr aber ich muss sagen
ich finde sie wissen bisher 25 von
gerade in der komplett verschiedene
varianten bei milch nicht ich finde es
leger ich kann mir vorstellen
oder rindfleisch noch dazu haben sie
danke fürs essen richtig gut kann es
öfter kochen gehören opa gut gefallen
oder wenn ihr möchte das haben sie öfter
mal mit nem vor die kamera tritt dann
halt jetzt sprengt die kommentare wie
schreibt hamza muss dabei sein und dann
machen wir das video dann kommst du
denkst du nicht davon nahm ist auf jeden
fall mit dabei die rezepte moniert den
kanal vielleicht wenn ihr abonniert
sprecher fekters und natürlich auf dem
blog kanäle und dann sonst niemand in
teil 2 sehen möchte liegt da springt
also ich bin mit ihm um 1000 kommentare
sind und antalya schon gar nicht auf
jeden fall wird man sagen haben die
verabschiedung sind kundschaft
bis zum nächsten kitzeln
[Musik]